it seems to me that this debate about
men's and women's rights is being
treated as a zero-sum game that seems to
be one of the fundamental issues that
we're butting heads against and you say
that people believe arguing for the
rights of men and boys would
automatically mean rolling back women's
rights or denying the existence of
misogyny that has to be probably one of
the Prime flash points when it comes to
putting this forward and how it's going
to be received culturally
yeah I think that's a big a big part of
the problem on both sides I think
sometimes the opposite is true perhaps
on you know on the other side of the
political Spectrum it depends who you're
talking talking to but for sure I think
that one of the problems is that that
even even conceding that we should do
some stuff for boys and men there is a
problem for them is seen as even if not
necessarily diverting resources away
from things for girls and women although
it could mean that it's much much more
about the distraction of attention
it's more of the are you kidding me
problem right it's more the you want me
to talk about boys and men when you know
six percent of companies are led by
women when on your court of
parliamentarians you know and I have my
my wife actually is in the in the
process of raising money uh for a
startup business so I know that only two
percent of venture capital money goes to
female Founders I I'm reminded of that
on a on a nightly basis Chris
um so I'm acutely aware that there's
still a lot of work to do for uh for
women in many areas especially at the
top of society and so it's just a sense
of like
no no we've it's unfinished business
over here a lot of unfinished business
over here and it's really difficult
right now in the current environment to
get people to think two thoughts at once
it's really hard to break away from this
sense of like can I still care about
that and care about this or am I having
to choose and unfortunately where it's
framed is it very often is a choice so
even if it's not as resource Zero Sum
and let's be clear sometimes it could be
right if there's only so much money to
spend on education say and some of it
does go for policies that are pro mail
which I would argue For You could argue
that that means less money is going into
some of the money for women scholarships
into stem or whatever it is okay so I
think you have to be honest about that I
would argue that that's now Justified
but it's a deeper problem than that it's
more just almost in the in the
conversation
you've got to pick sides and that merely
saying
boys and men are in trouble we need to
do to help more as a boys and men is to
betray any commitment to the needs of
women and girls and that false binary is
a really crippling the conversation I
think around this subjects one of the
reasons I wrote the book honestly is
because I just didn't see that many good
faith attempts to try and do this to try
and think two thoughts at once and say
okay create a permission space for a
conversation around this which does not
require people to give up previous
commitments but also opens their eyes to
the fact there are some pretty big
gender inequalities running the other
way now and so you have to decide are
you interested in inequality or you're
interested in girls and women and if
you're interested in girls and women
because that's what you care about you
that's what your institution does fine
but then we do need countervailing
institutions or policies that take the
other gender inequalities seriously we
can't just look through one eye
I think this very much has a social
signaling
stated preferences thing going on as
well that
a lot of women at the moment a lot of
people that are pushing for the
upholding of women and the pushing
forward for the progression that they
can have in terms of access to education
employment Family Support so on
are not thinking sufficiently deeply
about the problem do you not want your
daughters to grow up in a school where
they have strong male role models so
that they actually understand that they
don't need to fear men perhaps they come
from a fatherless home let's remember as
well that a lot of the policies are
chosen by people in the upper Elites and
yet they must harshly impact the people
that are poverty-stricken it's very much
a disparity between those that make the
rules and those that follow the rules
would it not be better for your sons
that you have to be able to grow up with
good examples good role models in and
around school the grandfather that
you've got that you care about that's
going to be looked after would it not be
better for the daughters that you have
that you say that you're trying to make
the world better for to have some
partners that they can actually respect
and contend with someone that's going to
be a competent caring well-respected
well-contributing Father Figure partner
in life Breadwinner whatever it might be
it seems like
not understanding the challenges that
are facing men
and boys
is putting women at a disadvantage as
well do you really want your daughters
to be in school with boys that can't sit
still and are so disruptive that that
must lead to worse education outcomes
for the girls that are in class with
them as well
that's why I think yeah that's exactly
that's why I think redshirting you know
boys or starting boys will be good for
girls actually it's one of the reasons
parents very often put their girls into
Single Sex schools if they get the
option twos is to get them away from the
disruptions that the boys have but I
think I think you're raising quite a
deep Point here which is how we think
about human flourishing across different
groups and
outside of a very small separatist part
of the feminist movement I don't think
many women would disagree
with pretty much everything you've just
said right including those who would
consider themselves card carrying
feminists right do they want boys and
men to flourish do they want their
husbands to be doing well do they want
their brothers to be doing what they
want yes they would say yes he's yes to
to all all of the above
um
the question then is
do you agree that some of them are
struggling
okay do you agree that some of the
reasons they're struggling are not just
their own individual frailties like some
like as we discussed it's not just a
psychological problem with your son it's
the problem with the school system
right do you agree with that there are
structural things here okay thirdly do
you agree we should do something about
those
in order to try and help boys and men
succeed we've got to go through all
three of those stages and I think a lot
of people are at stage one some people
at stage two I'm hoping to get people to
stage three which is okay let's do some
stuff about this then let's let's do
some stuff to to help if we agree there
is this strand of utopian feminism which
has always been about female only
societies
and and you see it back from Charlotte
uh Perkins her land
uh all the way through to that Rick and
Morty episode
um what's it raising
Gaza gazza's Thorpe or something another
one yeah where the guys are all like
living as barbarians on the planet and
and then there's this kind of serene
Society above and they kind of it they
brutally killed them they throw the
males out and they just get them to
inseminate and stuff but it's actually
like that there's a lot of literature
around this and of course you know
Wonder Woman from an all-female
all-female island the Amazons and so on
too and it's really speaking to
something I think which is this idea
that you could currently create this
perfect Society if only you could kind
of get rid of all the men
or some cording them off or put them on
a different planet or something like
that
um and it's always been an interesting
strand there's been much less of it
lately and of course the real world that
women want to live in is not a world
like that if you spoke to most women
they don't want to live in the world
without men they want to live in a world
where men are doing well and men treat
them well and they treat men well the
world you just described so well
um and so assuming that men and women
are going to continue to live together
and they're going to be lots of men and
women around
than helping each other to flourish is
surely the project here and for a very
long time that has meant paying a lot
more attention to women and girls and in
lots of the world that is still true
I wouldn't want to be misunderstood here
I don't think there's a big market for
my argument in Afghanistan
but in many parts of the world it's
absolutely true now that for to help
women flourish and kids to flourish we
need to help men to flourish as well
what's happening people if you enjoyed
that then press here for a selection of
the best clips from the podcast over the
last few weeks and don't forget to
subscribe
peace
[Music]